[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to episode 250
of congratulations
[Music]
oh okay dude it's episode 200 and
[ __ ] 50 dude what can i say what can
i say i'll tell you what i can say your
boy's got some [ __ ] color dude
yo you never [ __ ] looked better i
mean he's looked he probably looked
better five years ago but he never
looked better when it comes to about
five you know in between he looks okay
dude he looks [ __ ] okay he's not the
color off death anymore because he's
been sitting in the sun dude
and one fire said that he's [ __ ]
looked good and his skin looks really
good so it's [ __ ] on my babies hell
yeah dude
oh we have a good time though
i'll tell you what man we have a good
time pre-sale tickets are up on my tour
they're up on my tour on my website
and uh you go out there right now and if
you want to get the good seats you go
right now look if you want to get the
good seats to go right now that's it
if you don't want to get the good seats
you don't go right now but the pre-sale
is don't push me all lower case no
spaces
and no spaces in case you're geriatric i
say because only geriatric people don't
know about not putting spaces
in pre-sale tickets but go to
crystallia.com we got atlanta georgia
coming up we got washington d.c
stockton california for some reason
oakland peoria illinois rockford
illinois for some reason
raleigh north carolina we've got
savannah georgia denver we've got
cheyenne wyoming for some reason we've
got boston massachusetts
and we've got jackson florida
jacksonville florida not jackson florida
because that's not a thing so you go to
chrisleya.com if it's i'll tell you what
you go pre-sale if it's thursday if you
listen to this podcast on a thursday the
day it comes out which means you're a
true fan and you want to get the good
seats then you go you put the pre-sale
in you put don't push me you don't want
to get the good seats then you go friday
and you go on the general on sale either
way you're coming out to the shows i
can't wait to do uh these dates phoenix
was uh unbelievably fun and it was great
and the energy there was fantastic and
um
honestly
that's why he's got some color and
that's why he looks good because he's
got new life in him dude
he's got some new life in him
and uh i went swimming with the boy and
the family and it was just great but i
was in phoenix and uh we'll have that
vlog coming out on the more crystalia
channel later on but um
yeah we did phoenix
um we all went as a family i brought a
bunch of i brought craig conant killer
michael noche killer and i brought the
family calvin kane and kristen came and
we were in phoenix and um
yeah i mean jesus i don't even know what
to say man um it was the first out of
town gig that i did
that i took a flight to do um in three
years i mean the last time i did it i
think was the last show i did was
somewhere in florida i believe before
the pandemic just in 2019 um so it's
been three years um and uh it's just
been super
uh
i don't know man i i i've been doing a
lot of clubs and stuff and i i didn't
even realize that this was the biggest
venue that i'd done i mean this this
seats 2 700 seats or something and we
did two of them so it was absolutely
insane it was in the round i've never
played in the round before except for
the one time it was the same theater
that i
um
that i went to go uh
break into brian callan's set
um
it's in the round and that celebrity
theater is absolutely amazing i mean it
really is dude
and um i like playing in the round it's
different though because
you know
i do hear when when you're in the round
when you do a theater in the round you
and you do a joke you can definitely see
the people that you're looking at
laughing the hardest and they laugh
harder than the people behind you which
is very interesting and very interesting
and i know that's very interesting
because when i was telling it to ivan
gets rid of before this show he said oh
that's very interesting so that's very
interesting and um
the celebrity theater was great though
man the energy was [ __ ] bonkers you
could see on my instagram i posted a
video um and the vlog's coming in and
i'll go you know you'll see that too but
like at the end i brought kristen and
calvin and all and the other comedians
on stage and calvin came up with this
headphones kristin got him little
headphones
or uh
i guess earmuff headphones that they're
quieter noise reduction headphones you
know whatever the [ __ ]
and uh he came out with them on and
everyone was [ __ ] screaming so loud
and then they fell off and he started
crying so it was too loud so it's a good
thing good on christopher getting those
earmuff headphones um
but my god man i just feel honestly so
grateful and i know i say that a lot now
but i just really do
like i mean those fan man those people
the people who came out in phoenix those
people
you guys are something special like you
guys just
i mean when i took that stage and you
guys were just [ __ ] stood up and
started screaming i mean you
[ __ ] i feel like i saw all of
you we were all together right that's
what i'm talking about when i build this
log cabin man you're all invited we
gotta build one big [ __ ] log
cabin
you know
some of those dudes at the meet and
greet were [ __ ] big and burly they
can help you know i saw some tall drinks
of water come to the meet and greet dude
very very very personable very nice
people at the meet and greet
they said we know everyone always says
this no matter what town i'm in i know
this place sucks but thanks for coming
no i love it dude that's why i'm there i
picked phoenix one because it's one of
my favorite places to go
and it's so [ __ ] hot and i love it
man you step out you could put [ __ ]
fry an egg on that concrete but i loved
it dude
and everyone was complaining you know
mike linochie another comedian that came
with me he was like it's so hot and he's
sweating no matter what dude it's got to
be [ __ ] 69 degrees for him
but uh we stayed at kristen's uh mom's
house
which
is my new favorite thing to [ __ ] do
on the road is to be in a house man i
think i'm off this hotel's thing
but uh we got to the house and it was
just nice as [ __ ] we might do some
airbnbs you know what i mean just hire
some security to stand outside
just with [ __ ] big-ass shotguns
really small dudes with big-ass shotguns
i want to hire you know a lot of guys
hire big security guys i want to hire
[ __ ] small persons
just [ __ ] small
small
the smallest small people we can find
but like 40 years old but like super
like you know
small and like you know what i mean like
like a small person like i'm you know
what i'm talking about right like i
can't say the you do not but you do know
what i'm talking about but like they're
big almost as big as a shotgun like they
have to if you try to break in the
airbnb because you know crystallia is
there then you've got they drag the
shotguns over and they say you know hey
guys actually you got to step off the
lawn
crystally is here and then they say to
the other small person help me out
and then the hell one of them holds the
trigger and the other guy holds the
[ __ ] barrel like a bazooka
and they go step off the lawn baby
and um
so yeah but it was really nice we stayed
at her house my linoci and his girl
stayed there and then craig conan no he
didn't actually the cameraman sam stayed
but um
and it was [ __ ] nice to it
he likes the air at 69 i like the air at
78
and we compromised on 72 because it's
extra hot in phoenix and i loved it dude
i just love that heat people are like
huh the heat i'm like nope dude make me
evaporate i love it i want my lips
cracked that's the only thing that bad
about the heat is dry heat made my lips
crack and i could barely take it i
didn't take a poop the whole time i
don't take poops and when i go and the
shit's over 75 when the shit's over 80
degrees outside i don't take poops my
hand just goes like this i'm all good
i'm all good man
i'll sit on the toilet sometimes i think
i need to go you know what comes out
this sound me up nothing dude nothing
the anus just goes meow like it's
hitting a note
ha
that's what it does no poop comes out
i don't even think calvin i think calvin
like father like son dude
but calvin came with me to the show and
everyone came with me to the show and it
was just so beautiful man he kept saying
ah
yuck
it's time that dad does work he needs to
work on talking but dude it was so sweet
and i hugged him before i went on stage
and he gave me a high five before i went
on stage and i walked out there
and i just [ __ ] saw like kristen
holding him in the sometimes when i was
doing jokes and i saw [ __ ] it was
just beautiful man i love seeing you
guys you guys came out with the life
rips apparel i love it
all right enough of this man i'm just
super grateful and it was awesome
and then afterwards we came back
and i [ __ ]
was like let's turn on some shitty tv
you know how your boy likes to do it
turn on some shitty tv and then there
were those people that were like no no
you know i don't know man let's just
talk we have a good i'm like dude you
turn on some tv and you also talk though
because if you do that you get the best
of both worlds and then we ordered food
and it was terrible definitely got
cancer from it but we got you know it
was great we're sitting at my [ __ ]
mother-in-law's house eating [ __ ]
dirty burgers and just watching uh this
movie catch and release with jennifer
garner
in it
and uh i ended up falling asleep on the
couch with me which means one thing your
boy's peaceful dude if he's falling
asleep on the couch he's peaceful
especially in a room full of six people
dude and i went to fall asleep and
before i knew it the lights were out
and i'm waking up and mike lenocchi's
girlfriend is waking me up and i say huh
and she says do you want to go to bed
you fell asleep out here you're snoring
and i got pissed but couldn't get mad at
her because she's not my girlfriend
when someone's sleeping just let them go
dude why you got to wake him up to move
him
dude if i fall asleep at a baseball game
and the game's over leave me there
i've done it you wait hey hey
i don't [ __ ] agree with this hey hey
you want to go to you want to go
you want to go wake up and go to sleep
somewhere else huh
this is the goal
i uh dude goal
achieved
sleeping unlocked
hey
it's like dude we don't eat at
restaurants all the time you see a guy
walking in the down the sidewalk you
don't [ __ ] hey bro go in in the place
there there's a restaurant there go
ahead
you can sleep anywhere
hey wake up she goes like that and i go
huh she says you want to go in the bed
you're snoring and we all went to bed
and i go okay
she leaves
anger rising all good though right
because it's not you know it's adjacent
the way i know her i know her and she's
a great girl but it's adjacent how i
know her she's my friend now but just
you know what i mean like you thank god
when your [ __ ] friends have a cool
girlfriend thank god right
you know when your friend gets a
girlfriend you're like yeah look for
this will be great i can't wait to meet
her she shows up and it's just like whoa
here she comes
watch out or she'll chew you up whoa
here she comes and then she's just like
hey
and you're like oh no but in your head
she's a man-eater who watch out i
harmonize
mostly because i can't go high like that
whoa here she comes
watch out or she'll be chewing you up
the russian version the foreign version
whoa here she comes she eats man
who watch out
bobby shop quartet on my own
but it's just uh so she's a great bro my
buddy looked the [ __ ] out he's like i
lucked the [ __ ] out dude when you lock
the [ __ ] out with a girl holy [ __ ]
how many guys can say that honestly
how many guys can say that
you're probably driving into your car
right now i you know i can say that most
days
i know love is a hard thing right it's
ups and downs and ups and downs and ups
and downs and it keeps going and you
have your problems lord knows i've had
my problems right we've had our problems
in our relationship and mostly it's me
right okay do you know what i mean
mostly the problems are me right because
i'm me
and my brain's [ __ ] up but mostly it's
me but also it can be both of us but
even if it's sometimes her it's mostly
me right it turns back around on you
women can never really get in trouble in
your relationship you know because they
have that whole thing where they start
crying and then you go like this i'm
sorry and then you go
no
and you're just like great dude
and in their head they're just whoa here
he comes
watch out he's [ __ ] gaslighting whoa
here he comes he's a piece of [ __ ]
a douchebag
whoa here's here he comes
he doesn't do the dishes when he said he
would whoa here he comes
he promised to do them watch out
worst song ever
[Laughter]
dude whoa here he comes
he was hanging out with my friends whoa
here he comes i had to text him in
private when he was here
whoa here he comes i had to text him hey
can you act like you're interested whoa
here he comes
should have pulled him aside
it's his fault
so that's what's up dude
and you know what i'm saying it's very
relatable
so that's what that's what we did and
she [ __ ] woke me up and then i got
you know the anger was rising she went
to bed and then [ __ ] the tv was out
the lights were out and i go like this
man i just want to be asleep here but
i'm not you know what do it now dude do
it now do it [ __ ] now it was like a
guy had a gun to my head and i knew i
[ __ ] up do it now do it now do it
in my head and i just got up within one
fell swoop i went into the [ __ ]
bathroom took out my contacts and i
[ __ ] fell into bed dude
and i went off to dreamland
and then i woke up and guess what
happened
i woke up and i walk out to the kitchen
and kristen is with calvin and calvin is
chilling doing stuff like you know
he was playing with a dinosaur that he
really liked
a t-rex
and uh
i walk out there and i go i play with
the t-rex a little bit but i'm very very
i don't when i wake up dude my hair
looks like the [ __ ] a german at the
end of a movie in a [ __ ] james bond
or end of james bond movie right like
it's it's it's messed up it looks like
the plane's going down
it looks like i'm about to go no and
it's about to zoom in and then my face
is gonna illuminate with an explosion
that's what my hair looks like when i
wake up a german at the end of a james
bond movie
and um
[Laughter]
and then my glasses on but i oh i first
but i keep one eye for some reason when
i wake up i keep one eye [ __ ]
like half shut i don't know if i'm
acting in real life from like acting
more tired than i am you know sometimes
you're dramatic and [ __ ]
but i walked out and then i walked back
into the bedroom and now i'm in arizona
okay i walked back into the bedroom
all right
now
you're gonna be as confused as i was
when i tell you this story okay
i walk back into the bedroom and i'm
gonna go plop down onto the bed again
and before i go plop down into the bed
into the bed again
all of a sudden
searing pain in my big toe
and i don't mean like i stepped on a
nail
i mean like uh
hey
why does this pain keep growing every
second
and now i get so scared because i'm in a
foreign land i'm in the foreign land of
phoenix right
if i felt that
pain here in la i'd probably just sit
down and be like oh my god but i was in
phoenix so i thought what's happening my
whole world is not what my world usually
is because i'm [ __ ] however many
miles away 800 miles away from my house
so it could be anything we're in phoenix
is it a scorpion
i mean this pain was
searing dude and i go oh oh
oh
like that really loud
i go oh oh oh
and krista says what happened and i sit
down and i say i don't know
like that like a will ferrell character
and it gets harder and it hurts more and
i said what's happening what did i step
on i stepped on a b i looked down it's a
[ __ ] b
on the [ __ ] calvin's grandma's carpet
belly up
[Music]
dude the bee is already dead but just
[ __ ]
waiting to sting me dude
my [ __ ] big toe
felt like it was lopped off
and i looked down and a bee's [ __ ]
sleeping with the fishes
[Music]
there's a stinger
in
my foot
sometimes
you find out what kind of a man you
really are dude now how do i step on a
bee
inside
how does it happen
as a matter of fact i want to ask you
audience of congratulations
faithful babies
future log cal cabin residents
future tall grass sitters
dressed in white sharing ideas
i want to ask you
count how many bees you seen inside
me
one
belly up on grandma's carpet
dude i forgot how bad bee sting hurt i
forgot that i forgot about that
i forgot about that dude i forgot how
bad bee stings hurt did you know that
i've been stung by a bee three times all
right in my life once
no wait twice no four times
once i was a kid
and i was near a tree and i had my shirt
off and all of a sudden i felt that
searing sw that sweet searing pain on my
back and i ran faster than ever back to
my house i didn't know what happened my
mom said he got stung by a bee that was
one
number two
was when i was younger in new jersey
still both in new jersey i was
getting out of a pool
at the [ __ ] public pool i got out i
put my tummy down on the [ __ ]
uh
ledge
all of a sudden that sweet
sweet searing pain on my tummy screamed
a lot with goggles on ran to my parents
it was fine i was like nine okay you
could scream a lot when you're nine
number three i was at jiu jitsu okay
i leave jiu jitsu barefoot
out
i've told this story in my pockets
before i step on something it hurts
doesn't hurt that bad though i drive all
the way home to burbank and then i
realized holy [ __ ] did i step on a
syringe i'm scared i was in [ __ ] west
hollywood and in a parking lot and
there's [ __ ] addicts there so i drove
all the way back to check for the
syringe i'm like i'm never gonna find it
and there was
no lie a bee
belly up
on the parking lot
and the fourth time in my life was last
saturday on grandma's rug
and that one hurt so [ __ ] much i
can't even believe it
so
it's fine and i the one thing i said
that makes me know i'm a good person
when i got [ __ ] stung by a by a
[ __ ] bee that by a dead bee is
oh man thank god it was me you know
that's the kind of guy i'm dude
it's the kind of guy i am thank god it
was me
because i didn't want it to be calvin
right and then so when i was like
holding my foot i was like thank god it
was me it could have been calvin and
then i [ __ ] made sure because krista
was there i said or you like i wouldn't
want it to be her i'd rather it be me
but my heart was all i you know think
about [ __ ] calvin getting stung by
people we don't even know if he's
allergic yet calvin could get stung by a
bee and all of a sudden [ __ ] blow up
right
so thank god it was me that [ __ ] bee
and then i walked outside and mike
linoche was there dude and he was just
like yeah you know he's like so oh so he
stepped on a bee so what it doesn't hurt
it's dead you can't get stung by a dead
bee ain't wrong no images no women's the
women's the whims
you can do it
and he didn't know that so i taught him
a lesson
so i'm an educator and also he's dumb
um
so yeah i did that
and i made it through dude times get
hard but i made it through
ah
the phoenix trip they made me think
about [ __ ] like that kings of pain
right isn't that what it's called the
kings of pain show we talked about it
earl yeah dude they're doing a season
two of it it's on like something like
the outdoors channel or whatever the
[ __ ] there's like you know what i mean
discovery where the guys just take a
scorpion and they just [ __ ] put it on
their forearm and wait to the scorpion
stick dude i don't know how they do that
that b was enough for me what level was
is b i don't know they rate it though
they get hit [ __ ] bit by like a
[ __ ] python or whatever the poisonous
one is and then they're like they gotta
go like
sit there and rate the pain and it's
like dude one bee sting i'm out i'm done
dude if i was in kings of pain
i'm out
we go time for the beasting and i go
okay here we go sting i go oh oh
dude i gotta get in one of those jeeps
we gotta go back i gotta fly back dude
what the [ __ ] am i doing
i gotta fly back to america right now
what am i doing in africa let me the
[ __ ]
do i
these guys [ __ ] kill it dude
they go out and get [ __ ] and not just
like i feel like they got bit by so many
things earlier last season that this
this time it's going to be like
we're [ __ ] here we are at the
australian barrier reef or whatever
we're going to jump off and get
[ __ ] see see how much of uh see we're
going to rate great white bites
here we go and then just [ __ ] jump in
never see him again just a big pool of
blood of red blood and they go we rate a
sh a white sh a great white shark bite a
10.
the other guy's like oh man
and then he's like oh let's go try a
[ __ ] beetle
um and then ringo comes out us up and
just bites him worst joke ever um
as a guy
um sorry australian not british
[Music]
you guys have heard of ship station
haven't you or are you living under a
rock
when you run a business time seems more
precious every misplaced moment feels
like a missed opportunity a lost chance
to make your business better or even
just to step away and recharge right all
that stuff's important shipstation gives
e-commerce sellers like you more time to
do what they really love unless you're
unless what you really love is managing
every single little detail of order
fulfillment but we don't right because
we're human and i hate doing that and i
know you probably hate doing that too so
shipstation what it does is it automates
time intensive shipping processes so you
can get back to focusing on bigger
things like developing new products uh
honing your marketing strategies or
interacting with cus customers all the
important stuff that you should be doing
my favorite thing about shipstation is
when i you know the fact that we use it
all of my customers and people who order
stuff for me uh they're just happy
because they're getting their merch fast
and hassle free um i see people posting
stuff like that they're like i got this
a day later and stuff like that and it's
just great um
so yeah all those manual shipping tasks
uh are if they're eating up your time
shipstation takes care of all of that um
it's really good at those so let
shipstation handle all your shipping and
handling and get back to what you're
good at growing your business uh it's
time to let all of those shipping tasks
go
um shipstation can do it better and
faster sign up using promo code congrats
for a free 60-day trial today you got
nothing to lose at shipstation.com
and start saving time with every
shipment that's two whole months of
shipping made quick and painless and
it's free to try just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in
congrats shipstation make ship happen
crazy
crazy
crazy
uh so yeah anyway kings of payne i
stepped on a bee so that's cool
ah
the phoenix trip was cool man
when i was coming home um
well two things happened that
one thing happened that made me feel
like i'm pretty i dated a girl once
probably 10 no it was 10 years ago yeah
and she would always say
i hate loud sounds and i hate like
sounds that don't agree with me and like
it bothers me so much
and i always thought it was so silly
because i'm just like they're just
sounds who gives a [ __ ] what are you a
dolphin you know and she would be like i
just like loud noises or like when
somebody's being annoying it's like
really puts me off and i'm like
all right and i think about that all the
time and now i'm [ __ ] like that okay
i was on the plane dude
and
you know my family's sleeping calvin's
watching the ipad and all he's doing is
he's watching a [ __ ] ipad um
everyone's uh
chris is sleeping kevin's watching on
ipad that is like uh it's this [ __ ]
really colorful cartoon on
some streaming service
i guess netflix he downloaded it and
he's like all he's doing is playing with
the brightness of it i look and it's
just going bright and dark bright and
dark and i look and he's just [ __ ] i
don't even know how to do it but he's
sitting there just [ __ ] you know he's
already more technologically advanced
than i am on an ipad and um
and i'm watching him do it and he's
doing it for like a [ __ ] the whole
flight and i'm sitting there and i keep
hearing now now you know how loud a
[ __ ] plane is right like it's just
it's always humming it's never not
humming if a plane's not humming you're
about to die but you're on the plane
you're 30 000 feet in the air and i hear
humming but i also hear
and then for a while i don't hear it so
i'm like
what the [ __ ] where is that
is it in my head
how close would somebody have to be to
you if you're on a plane and then you
hear
that was the exact noise
ah
[ __ ] yeah dude
dude i'm so comfortable during this
podcast that i'll sneeze i don't get
insecure
[ __ ] yeah dude you understand how happy
that makes me
i'm so comfortable that i i think oh i
got to sneeze and then i don't think uh
oh i think we'll let you know no just
roll with it dude because i'm wrong what
you see is what you get and that's my
duty to you guys because this is a cult
i would never [ __ ] not sneeze for you
[ __ ] yeah dude
sneeze with me
if you really respect someone you'll
sneeze around you're around you'll
sneeze around them but anyway um
i did that for you and you know it's
like i don't want to be like you're
welcome but it's a gift and like it's
all good
so i'm sitting there and
now the [ __ ]
flight is an hour and five minutes
by the way airlines just say like an
hour you don't need to like
how long is a flight they're always so
smug with it 111.
okay you know just say
it's gonna be about an hour
you know
the flight time to denver is currently
three hours and 23 minutes all right
dude what do you think like i'm you're
gonna it's gonna be 325 and i'm going to
be like oh you know you gotta [ __ ]
you lied
so i hear
and i'm like all right
where is it you know what i mean and i'm
getting [ __ ] and i but i'm like i
think the guy in front of me is making
that noise so i do the thing where like
appear i'm in the one seat you know i'm
in the one row seat because i'm in first
class and i [ __ ] look and i don't
mean to [ __ ] brag but you know what i
mean no dents and so i [ __ ] look
over to the crack of
the inside and the
and the
chair
and and i think i'm going to say
something to him if he's making this
noise and i look and he's watching
something on his phone and it's set up
and i look and i think well what's he
watching right and it's in [ __ ] it's
got spanish subtitles on it so i'm like
the guy [ __ ] maybe doesn't even speak
english so now i can't even [ __ ] say
anything to him right but
guess what dude
is a universal language
so i'm pissed in all the languages with
but it's like it's like
shooting through the [ __ ] hum of the
airplane you know what i mean it's like
not it's not loud or soft enough but
it's just that
so i'm like i got to see what the [ __ ]
this guy's doing so i think i don't want
to be a [ __ ] i'm no [ __ ] i gotta lean
forward and if he sees me who cares
right
so i lean forward
and and i and i can't see it because i'm
like he's just gonna [ __ ] see me look
at his mouth but i didn't want to get up
and walk pretend to go to the bathroom
and come back and see if he was doing it
because first of all the timing is wrong
and then also the timing may be wrong
but then also he's making me do all this
extra work because of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] sound on me and i should be
able to do what the [ __ ] i want i don't
need to be getting some extra steps
because of this guy's mouth sucking
which i don't even know if that's what
the noise is right
so all this stuff's going on in my head
right
and
i'm like great i can't lean forward hard
enough to see because he's like [ __ ]
slumped over watching this [ __ ]
and i can't see this way and i can't see
this way
so i'm like you know what i'm gonna do
because i'm a [ __ ] badass i'm gonna
take my phone i'm gonna put it in the
camera mode face it in the selfie right
selfie mode and then i'm gonna [ __ ]
just go like this in front of him to see
what the [ __ ] he's doing dude
and i want you to [ __ ] know
deep down in your heart
that that's how gangster i am dude if
you're making
mouth noises
but it's not confirmed and you're
sitting in front of me
on an airplane or anywhere
and i'm you know and you're trying to
get me to do some extra work to [ __ ]
walk forward and look back to see if
you're doing it i'm not gonna do that
dude
i'm sitting down and i'm chill
[ __ ] axed
i'll [ __ ] put my phone in selfie mode
and i'll put it in front of your face
and act like
we're having a moment dude that we have
to capture
so that's what i did dude i put it in
selfie mode
you know i got a little bit of ner you
know you get nerves the whole thing
about the no fear it's like what if he's
gonna see oh no don't have fear be a man
about it dude i felt fear
i felt nervous
but a real man doesn't feel no fear a
real man
feels fear
and still perseveres
and i've learned all about that this
past two years
so this guy
i mean his immense meat
phone activated in selfie mode
moved it forward way in front of his
face
and i'm like he's going to see
because i didn't angle it right at first
and i'm angry i'm trying to get the
angle and i get it and i and bro oh
whoopsy daisy i didn't even tell you the
phone was [ __ ] recording video
he's got evidence too
it wasn't just in selfie mode jokes on
you he's got evidence too
who's picking his teeth
with the razor
hey bud
first of all why
second of all
did you get it on the plane
how'd you get it
how
to get it on the plane dude
also
now i'm recording a guy
who doesn't speak english
sticking razors in his mouth
trouble
but i got it and you know what dude i
didn't even get his face in it because
i'm good with the [ __ ] camera you
know
so i'll put it up here in the [ __ ]
congratulations and i'll show you but he
had a [ __ ] razor and he was picking
his teeth for so long
and i didn't say anything about him but
i recorded the video and i sent it to
all my friends so
i won that one
he's petty but he knows the deal you
know what i'm talking about yeah sure
crystallia that guy who's petty yeah but
he knows the deal no i know
that's how people talk when they talk
about me crystalia who's that the petty
guy yeah no but he knows the deal no i
know but i'm saying
picking your teeth in public is always
it's just it's like it honestly for real
instead of that turn around open up your
anus and let [ __ ] leak out less gross i
i mean it too like it's just so gross to
hear the
like any burp is worse than a fart dude
if i'm around you and you fart i go come
on man if you burp you're off my list
that's so gross that's stale stomach
energy gross as [ __ ] dude just coming
out the bile just [ __ ] the [ __ ]
bile's done
just coming out of the [ __ ] air
inside you all that bile just [ __ ]
doing it like this like a daffy duck
cartoon bile's done
bile's done
i don't know man
it's the little [ __ ] that we talk about
that's really important for this world
so that's what happened that was
annoying on the plane and then when i
went when i landed i had to go change
calvin
because he took a [ __ ] poop in his
diaper finally because we were out of
that dry zone
as soon as we landed he just [ __ ]
you know dropped some pebbles out
and i had to go change him because uh
kristen had to i don't remember where
she was but i [ __ ] went to uh the
men's room to go change them and there
was like no changing area there was just
like a ledge like come on airport get it
together you know it was just a ledge it
wasn't even a [ __ ] there was like no
it wasn't comfy at all and i was like
come here buddy and i had to put him up
there and i was like can you sit down
and he sat down on this hard ledge and
then he had he's like no i want dinosaur
and he had his dinosaur and so i was
like that's okay and i took i got to
take her pants down and undid it and
right and it's his [ __ ] father and
son i'm changing his diaper in the
uh bathroom
and i hear and there's a lesson for yeah
me by is what i mean and i hear this
dude in the bathroom and he's just like
god damn man those shoes look comfy as
[ __ ]
i just hear some guy say god damn man
those shoes look comfy as [ __ ] and it's
too far away to be about me so i'm
pissed and i'm not pissed that he's not
talking about how comfy my shoes look
but it's just like don't be that loud to
somebody you either know or don't know
in a [ __ ] public bathroom and it was
that loud too also don't it's so echoey
in bathrooms he just says god damn no
shoes look comfy as hell
just like that okay and the guy and then
another guy says quieter oh yeah they're
pretty comfy but you know i like him
he's like yeah man they're really nice i
really like them
and it's just loud as [ __ ] and i'm
changing calvin and i'm focusing on them
you know i'm just like buddy you know
hold on and he's starting to cry and i'm
like buddy just hold on your dinosaur
it's okay let me get it let me clean you
up all right cool now stand up here we
go and then i turn around as i turn
around
i see this [ __ ]
the two guys a black dude with steel
blue eyes i mean this guy had to be 50
but boy dude he looked [ __ ] handsome
as [ __ ] and he said
hey you're a good dad man and he had the
same voice as the guy who said god damn
those shoes look comfy as hell and i was
upset and then when he said that and he
looked at me and he said you're a good
dad
it made me feel better than [ __ ]
anything
so i was upset at the [ __ ] t-second
guy and then i got a little bit
perturbed when the guy was screaming in
the bathroom but then it turned out that
that guy was the guy that gave me a
compliment and not only a compliment but
the best comment compliment a father
could have and if the old warmer side
and behind him the guy with the comfy
shoes 75 years old and just looks at me
and goes like this yep
and gives me a thumbs up dude
i'm walking on sunshine oh
it's bound to feel good
and almost i actually almost cried in
the [ __ ] bathroom dude and it would
have been okay because calvin was crying
too
[ __ ] yeah a black dude with steel blue
eyes and a [ __ ] old white dude with a
com shoes comfy as hell oh my god they
didn't know each other but they made
friends in the bathroom and then they
made friends with me
just unfucking believable life is great
if you just [ __ ] you know what i mean
if you focus on all these moments if you
just focus on them and you really
understand what you're going through and
living inside your body and not
sleepwalking through life you know what
i mean it's just beautiful because i was
sleepwalking through life for so long
and now i just [ __ ] walls down like
the star wars shits
i just feel good dude
you know what sometimes the you know the
[ __ ] gets to me like the mundane stuff
in life with the teeth sucking and you
know some days i'd have bad days but
then i [ __ ] you know i just think
about how great you gotta [ __ ] life
rips man that's why i always say this
dude but it does man
this guy came up to me after my show in
phoenix in the meet and greet and he was
like yo man i just gotta tell you dude
you you know
my buddy dot my buddy uh
died he he i can't remember what he said
but he
i don't think it was suicide but he said
my buddy died earlier this year
and uh
you know your podcast helped me get
through it it was like i was really sad
and like it just like you really saved
me this year
um and um i don't know if he you know
i'll just be [ __ ] candid with you
because it's not like i'm [ __ ] airing
this guy out but it was just a guy i'm
talking about that you don't know who he
is but he was like i don't think i'd be
here if it wasn't for your podcast and
you know he was probably just speaking
hyperbole but um
i said to him i was like
you know he he got a little bit like
emotional like his voice started
cracking and i gave him a hug and i said
uh
i'm i'm i'm really sorry to hear that
about your friend but i'm glad you're
still here and then we hugged and i said
and in his ear i said life rips man
and
and it does dude you know
because life can't be good without the
bad you know what i'm talking about if
it was all good if it's all good it's
not good right this i thought life was
all good until the bad happened and then
i realized how good life was
you know
that's so [ __ ] true
like you know
you sit there and you think you you
watch
comedians
you you know you watch comedians and
some of them aren't that good
and you're like these guys
are terrible you know you might watch a
comedian this is awful
but then you see a guy that just crushes
and you're like oh yeah and you
appreciate him more
because you [ __ ] realize stand up is
hard
and the cream rises to the top and the
good moments in life
can't rise to the top if there are no
other moments
he says while sipping on that purple
straw
life is
i always think about that thing where
chris rock said life is longer than a
[ __ ] you know people say life is
short i always thought that was so funny
and it is but like when you get older
like it [ __ ] you really think about
things
like this poor kate spade by the way i
mean i know she she uh
hung herself what was it like three
years ago but the [ __ ] what was it
ultra beauty
that like put out an email that was like
they put out a new fragrance and it was
and it like the tagline was come hang
with kate spade
so uncouth
it's one of those things that's so
bad and such an oversight and mistake
where you're like did they mean to
and of course they're getting dragged
online because everyone's [ __ ] just
wants them to you know this place should
be out of business and obviously they
didn't mean to do it because who the
[ __ ] would do that right it's not like
their [ __ ] uh
company is run by a menace although
maybe it is because i watched a little
bit about
i watched some documentary not about not
about the ultra beauty but about like
big corporations i watched the
documentary you watch a documentary
about big corporations dude it's the
most depressing [ __ ] because people are
like
what would i watch the other day
it was on hbo max
i don't remember dude something about
wall street
oh it was about the [ __ ] gamestop
thing
where they did the gamestop
the gamestop uh where everyone put money
into gamestop and gamestop exploded and
then and then it [ __ ] up the whole
economy like people [ __ ] lost their
houses because game stock stock was
going up how [ __ ] ridiculous is that
just a [ __ ] video game
brick and mortar video game store where
in a world where everyone can download
video games
just obviously failing
and people on reddit at wall street bets
were just like let's just actually see
if we can make people lose homes
[ __ ] the man
and so they [ __ ]
they just started [ __ ] it up and then
robin hood the app the the tr the
trading app came in and was like we're
actually gonna cease it you know
and uh but people lost their homes and
[ __ ] just because everyone was buying
gamestop and then like and then gamestop
uh
is still gonna
go to the [ __ ] wayside you know
but i was watching this thing and these
people on this documentary were just
like
you know if i could have a little part
of just you know [ __ ] these guys on
wall street i would love to have that i
would love to be a part of that just
[ __ ] the man and you're just like huh
everyone's so mad at people with money
and i'm not saying that right or wrong i
have no [ __ ] idea i'm not gonna
pretend i know any side of anything
right because how do you know unless
you're in the [ __ ] thing like i don't
know how evil these guys are sir bernie
madoff right he went to jail for 150
years for doing all that [ __ ] but like i
don't know how i don't know this [ __ ]
like people say the guy who did the
[ __ ] uh we work is a crook he's out
he's not he's not jealous he's got
[ __ ] 20 million dollars it's like
okay but i don't know and then all and
then also he's not a crook but then
[ __ ] what's her name the the theranos
girl she is a crook i don't know this is
like they did the same thing but one of
them had to do with you know lying about
curing cancer so i guess that's worse i
don't know
and everyone's out there with their
[ __ ] opinion and everyone's out there
making documentaries with these people
who have an opinion that when they take
down the man and i don't know who's
right
but that's what's up
all i'm saying is don't push me
right don't push me we got that [ __ ]
merch up in the store don't push me
crystallite.com
and we going to many many different
cities
boston cheyenne denver savannah rally
raleigh sorry whoops rockford
peoria and peoria
and new york it's a little shop of ours
just did a little [ __ ] ditty for you
oakland california stockton washington
d.c and atlanta georgia dude
i'm gonna try and get bob to come out
[ __ ] blb is gonna come out in my
[ __ ] atlanta show you said you heard
it here first dude i'm gonna make him
come
wait
pause pause
i do that i say pause sometimes
um
god it's so funny but when you do if
you're a comedian and you do stand up
and then there's a black audience and
you make a gay joke they'll laugh that
you could be killing if you make a gay
joke with a black audience they'd be
like there's nah nah nah
they do not [ __ ] with gay humor dude nah
b nah that's too far b
that's what they do
yeah dude you'd be crushing talking
about the kitchen just [ __ ] crushing
doing some kitchen humor yeah and you
ever use a [ __ ] black and decker
[ __ ] this and they'd be [ __ ] dying
dude and then your woman comes in and ah
and then you [ __ ] your friends
[Music]
never that
okay you don't like that let me go into
my [ __ ] animal humor and you start
doing other humor and they [ __ ] just
die and start dying again or just start
talking about other [ __ ] [ __ ] dying
and then you say yeah dude and then you
just start sucking a guy's dick
nah b
nah pause on that huh
pause on that dog
i was talking i was making fun of uh
something on the podcast the other day
and [ __ ] people online were saying i
was racist whatever
i'm not i was talking about asians and
how like [ __ ] great they are or
something and people were like this is
racist
thought we cancelled this guy and i'm
just like whatever that's the thing
about it
you cancel a guy he can say whatever he
wants now what are you gonna [ __ ] do
i'm gonna [ __ ] run for president dude
uh you know what
he screamed while he stepped up to the
purple straw and those four shots went
into his mouth effortlessly and down his
esophagus dude i'm a [ __ ] poet man i
should write a novel and just [ __ ]
use words like effortlessly dude you
know how [ __ ] good that would be dude
you know you're reading a [ __ ] good
novel when you when you when you read
words like effortlessly right and he
effortlessly strides through the hallway
dude
extra words of the [ __ ] in books man
that's why books are so long all books
should be under 220 pages dude if
there's if there's books that are longer
than 220 pages they're using words like
effortlessly not even big words but
words that have a lot of letters in them
like effortlessly dude that's how you
know this [ __ ] is on dude that's when
you know you're reading something that
they're going to turn into a movie in 20
years and use the [ __ ] guy who is in
the [ __ ] bad guy in wonder woman he's
going to be in it
[Laughter]
who's that [ __ ] guy god damn he's in
everything because he's [ __ ] latino
dude what's he's a good actor though
right he was in narcos
what the narcos didn't know what what
the what what the what was the [ __ ]
what's the thing what the cartel didn't
know was
how much voice over that the narcos had
what the what the police didn't know was
but what they didn't understand was we
understood everything but what they
didn't know was
we were so educated on this topic
um
they didn't have the education that we
had we were educated on this topic so
when we when the plane touched down
what the narcos didn't want us to what
they didn't want us to know was but we
already were miles ahead of them
dude i need to start doing some
voiceovers man
my son dances so much it's crazy dude
and it's not even that good but it's
cute as [ __ ] i guess if he was a good
dancer be less cute it'd be weird when
he [ __ ] when he's a
i don't when little kids are good at
[ __ ] i don't like that like you know do
you ever see like who is that [ __ ]
one dakota fan was she a child actress
is that her name and she was like
[ __ ] eight on the couch in leno and
she was like well i'll tell you jay and
you're just like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa look at how weird is that you
know what i mean
no knock i'm sure she had a great
childhood and great parents but it's
just like when you see a kid that's just
like hello howie mandel what i'll be
doing tonight on america's got talent is
and you're just like uh
don't be so polite man if you're a kid
be rude you know how much calvin says no
and i say hey you can't say that but
secretly i know you can and i love that
he's doing it because being defiant is
[ __ ] amazing because you know what
sucks rules but i go by him right
i go by him because then if anything bad
happens it's your fault
[Music]
he's got [ __ ] he looks nice dude he
looks nice with the [ __ ] dmx chain
and the [ __ ] kenzo shirt with the
[ __ ] nice little bit of color he got
in phoenix dude he looks nice with the
salt and pepper beard and he wishes it
was in his hair more but it's not dude
and he lets nature
do its thing i'm not the kind of guy who
dyes my hair never died [ __ ] never dyed
my hair once not even as a kid when all
the wrestlers were doing it with the
blonde hair i wasn't a wrestler but also
it leaked out into the other population
of the school and everyone started dying
their hair yellow like [ __ ] eminem
but this was even before eminent but
your boy never succumbed to that dude
because any time lots of people are
doing some [ __ ] your boy waits on the
sidelines for it to end
[Music]
lots of renters but dude he feels good
man okay
and uh yeah dude i never dyed my hair i
see sometimes people say dude what you
dye your hair bro
and it's like why would i dye only my
head hair
you ever think of that do a little bit
more this is what i have to say about
people
just in general
do a little bit more thinking before of
what you're going to say
do a little bit
more
thinking
i posted a picture about how i'm gonna
be on my on my uh what do you call it on
my uh um
instagram where i'm gonna be and [ __ ] in
my uh cities
and just
this is the this is the caption
announcement 10 a.m your time on
wednesday pre-sale code don't push me
get the good tickets quick they'll go be
ready let's do this link in bio and
somebody posts
where do we get the tickets
like i just don't understand
you know
i don't understand
what's happening in the most basic way
um
but yeah i got to take a piss i'll be
right back
okay we're back here i'm gonna watch
this video i saw this week and
this is the most insecure freestyle of
all time it's not an idol one of the
idol shows what is it like [ __ ]
russian idol american isle russian
american idol whatever the [ __ ] it is
first of all those shoes bang whatever
that guy's wearing these shoes are
unbelievable it says the best audition
freestyle ever also if this is american
idol they don't do rappers you know but
he raps and he does a freestyle and this
kid just basically looks like a school
shooter so here's the um
here's the freestyle he does
i hope you're feeling my flow if not
[ __ ] it made me late for my show
oh
real deep
because i don't give a [ __ ] you poke
[ __ ] if you're like me
go and don't stop
if you're like me oh wow if you're like
me suck my [ __ ]
you know
such a weird kink are you like me suck
my [ __ ] dude [ __ ] she says oh stop
dude that reminds me one time when i was
in new york i was i went to new york
university for a [ __ ] almost a year
uh
and uh
uh
i had a
a roommate named onshul
who now that i think about it not that i
not that i think about it i knew back
then but he was like a big fan of osama
bin laden and i didn't even know who
that was back then because it was before
9 11. and boy do i know who he is now
but he was just like um
we didn't like each other you know i'm
gonna be honest
he just didn't
he didn't like my uh my humor i think
um
and anyway he uh
one time i was singing
that song i wanna lick you up and down
until you say stop and he said stop and
i laughed so hard dude the guy annoyed
me so much i left school before he did i
was never gonna see him again and i took
the receiver of the phone and i [ __ ]
threw it away like a [ __ ] little
[ __ ] i threw the receiver the phone
this way when the phone rang and
somebody tried to call him it would just
ring and ring and ring and he couldn't
get the receiver but that's payback dude
that's payback for being a dick to me
and liking osama bin laden anyway dude
so this is like this lady's like stop
stop stop dude this freestyle
i hope you found it
if not [ __ ] it made me late for my show
i'm a real g why is he sounding like a
robot i'm a real g you know i'm late for
my show i'm a royal g
coleslaw
go and don't stop uh stop stop stop
if you're like me suck my [ __ ]
wow
look these are the dates dude all right
these are the f these are the [ __ ]
dates i'm doing
and these are the for and don't you know
you could be like what about
chicago yeah they're cut they're all
coming dude just
right now this is what we're doing
atlanta georgia
september 9th washington dc september
10th stockton california oakland peoria
october 7th
raleigh october 21st savannah denver
colorado november 5th
cheyenne wyoming november 6.
boston massachusetts and jacksonville
florida in december so go to crystal.com
get those good tickets and you have to
put in the code if you're listening to
this on thursday put in the code don't
push me if you listen to this on friday
then just go and get those tickets but
get the good seats with the code on
thursday or wednesday or thursday what's
the past wednesday well patreon people
will hear this well that's the episode
for youtube today if you want to catch
the rest of the episode the uncut
episode go over and go on over to
patreon.com uh chris slash
at patreon.comcrystalia and that's where
you get the rest of the episode you also
have
13 other episodes because we release one
every month that is not for the public
only for patreon subscribers so go binge
watch them now sign up
patreon.comcrystalia
and we also have other things that we do
behind the scenes stuff and also uh this
segment we do called review mode where
we review lots of stuff like movie
trailers and thanksgiving dinner and all
that [ __ ] anyway chrisley.com
or
well no patreon.com
[Music]
all right let's do it